[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مرحبًا ،
إنه صامت تمامًا بحيث
يمكنك البدء في سماع
كل الشمس تدخل فعليًا عبر
نسيجك وعظامك
حتى تسمع مثل ضغط
دمك يمكنك سماع دقات القلب
التي يمكنك  اسمع أوتارك حتى
نبدأ أولاً في الحصول على هذه
التجربة الصوتية الداخلية الشائعة ،
كان لدينا ميكروفون في المدرسة كان لدينا ميكروفون
في الماوس
مثل ميكروفون صغير وكان لدينا أيضًا
ميكروفون على الصندوق
لذلك قمت بإعداد مجموعة من الأعمال اليدوية الغريبة
ميكروفون
بسماعة طبية به مثل الجيوفون بمقاييس
التسارع المشابهة أو
الميكروفونات شديدة الحساسية
قضيت بضع ساعات معه أسجل جسده وعضلاته
وكل شيء من الجراثيم البنية
تمكنا من وضعه مثل الضوضاء الوردية في أذنه
حتى نتمكن من محاكاة حالات مختلفة
من  فقدان السمع
كان لديه جهاز من خلال سدادة أذن
لإعطاء التجربة الجسدية
له وأعتقد في هذا النوع من المواقف
الجسم لا يكذب
انظر مرة أخرى
أردنا أن يظل هذا الصوت
مثل الهيما  إن
الأمر ليس مثل الروبوت أو أنه ليس
مثل الصورة الرمزية
التي تعرفها هو ، ولكن يبدو أنك
لم تسمع شيئًا من هذا القبيل أبدًا
أعتقد أنه كان شيئًا خاصًا
جدًا للفيلم بالنسبة
لي
وزرع عملي هو الذي يخدع
عقلك في التفكير
عندما  في الواقع
، من النادر جدًا أن يكون لدينا موضوع يتعلق
بالصوت من الناحية الفنية ،
فهو قريب جدًا من العمل الوثائقي
والطريقة التي يعمل بها الأشخاص معًا
كما تعلمون كانت رائعة
[موسيقى]